>> Laura: AS TRUMP WAS
RELAUNCHING HIS REELECTION
CAMPAIGN IN FLORIDA, OUR OWN
RAYMOND ARROYO TALKS TO
PROTESTERS AT AN ANTI-TRUMP
EVENT TWO BLOCKS AWAY.
THEY REVEALED A NEW LINE OF
THINKING ON THE LEFT, A DEEPLY
NEGATIVE VIEW OF THEIR HOME
COUNTRY.
>> YOUR PLACARDS AS AMERICA WAS
NEVER GREAT, WHY DO YOU SAY
THAT?
>> BECAUSE WE SLAUGHTERED AN
ENTIRE PEOPLE TO GET OUR LAND?
>> WE ARE ALL FREE, WE CAN COME
OUT HERE AND SAY OUR PEACE.
>> I THINK YOU'RE ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF THE BRIDGE.
>> Laura: THAT LANGUAGE MIGHT
BE EXPECTED FROM AN ACTIVIST,
MORE PROMINENT VOICES ARE NOW
CONTRIBUTING TO THE WARPED
MIND-SET.
>> LET'S MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN, WHEN YOU THINK AMERICA
WAS GREAT?
>> WE AREN'T GOING TO MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, IT WAS
NEVER THAT GREAT.
>> THINGS ARE SAVAGELY WRONG IN
THIS COUNTRY, WHAT WE ARE SEEING
DOESN'T REFLECT OUR SPIRIT.
IT DOESN'T REFLECT OUR POTENTIA
POTENTIAL.
>> Laura: IT'S ONE OF THE
GREATEST TIMES EVER TO BE AN
AMERICAN, JOINING ME NOW WITH
REACTION FORMER SPEAKER OF
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
NEWT GINGRICH.
ARE WE ON THE SIDE OF PROPORTION
OR MANY OF THE MOST PROMINENT
VOCAL VOICES AND THE ACTIVISTS
ON THE GROUND REALLY JUST A VERY
ABOUT DEFAMING THE FOUNDATIONS
AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF OUR HOME
COUNTRY?
THE HATRED IS PALPABLE.
>> I THINK IT'S AMAZING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THIS KNACK
FOR FRAMING THINGS IN SUCH A WAY
THAT HIS OPPONENTS GO CRAZY.
YOU NOW HAVE FOR EXAMPLE THE
PRESIDENT SAYS KEEP AMERICA
GREAT WHICH I THINK IS A GREAT
CAMPAIGN SLOGAN FOR NEXT YEAR.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY NO, KEEP
AMERICA WEAK.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS I'M PROUD TO
BE AN AMERICAN, THE LEFT SAYS
I'M ASHAMED TO BE AN AMERICAN.
THE NUMBER OF LIES BEING TOLD
RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES ARE ASTONISHING
BUT ALL TRUMP IS DOING IS HE'S
DRAWING TO THE SURFACE THE DEEP
HATRED WHICH ON-CAMPUS IS
CERTAINLY BEGAN BY THE MIDDLE OF
THE 1960s AND HAS GROWN AND
GROWN LIKE A CANCER.
YOU'RE NOW SEEING WITH LEADING
NATIONAL DEMOCRATS AND THEY HAVE
A REAL PROBLEM.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT TODAY AND
GO TO A NORMAL DEMOCRATIC
MEETING AND START TALKING ABOUT
HOW WONDERFUL AMERICA IS, HOW
GREAT THE FOUNDING FATHERS WERE,
HOW REMARKABLE THE CONSTITUTION
IS, HE WOULD BE BOOED OFF THE
STAGE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE A PARTY WHICH
IS GENUINELY ANTI-AMERICAN,
THAT'S PRETTY REMARKABLE.
>> Laura: WE'VE MOVED FROM
WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE IN THE
1980s, IT WAS RONNIE RAYGUN.
A MUSHROOM CLOUD OVER THE
SOVIET UNION, IT WAS RIDICULING
HIM, WE ALL FORGET HIM NOW IN
THE GLOW OF REAGAN BIOGRAPHERS
BUT THEY WERE TRASHING HIM.
THEY WERE SAYING AMERICA AT HER
CORE IS ILLEGITIMATE BECAUSE THE
FOUNDING WAS ILLEGITIMATE, THE
FOUNDERS WERE RACIST -- BUT THIS
HAS GROWN WITH SOCIAL MEDIA AND
GROWN WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
NOMADIC PREVALENCE OF 24-HOUR
MEDIA, HOLLYWOOD IS
EMBOLDENED.
YOU'RE RIGHT, TRUMP HAS A WAY OF
DRAWING OUT WATER ANTI-AMERICAN
MADNESS AND REGULAR PEOPLE ARE
GOING I LOVE MY COUNTRY.
MY GOD, I WOULDN'T WANT TO LIVE
ANYWHERE ELSE.
>> 1984, JEANNE KIRKPATRICK
CAPTURED THIS, SHE HAD BEEN
HUBERT HUMPHREY'S ADVISOR.
SHE WAS ORIGINALLY A MODERATE
DEMOCRAT AND SHE GRADUALLY HAD
BEEN DRIVEN OUT OF THE PARTY BY
THE LEFT WING.
SHE HAD THIS AMAZING SPEECH
WHICH IS WORTH OUR AUDIENCE
GOOGLING AND PULLING UP, SHE
TALKED ABOUT THE LAME AMERICA
FIRST DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE ALWAYS
BLAMING AMERICA FIRST.
IF YOU WATCHED THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR DAYS TALKING ABOUT
CONCENTRATION CAMPS WHICH IS A
TOTAL, ABSOLUTE LIE.
IT IS SMEARING AMERICA, IT IS
INSULTING TO EVERYBODY WHO IS
GENUINELY WORRIED ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST AND THE CONCENTRATION
CAMPS IN WHICH 6 MILLION WERE
KILLED AND MILLIONS OF OTHER
PEOPLE WERE KILLED AND YET ON
THE LEFT TODAY AS WE WATCH
RECENTLY WITH VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN, BIDEN TELLING THE TRUTH
ABOUT FRIENDSHIPS THAT WERE
UNACCEPTABLE WAS MORE DAMAGING
THAN ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
SAYING THINGS THAT ARE
ABSOLUTELY, TOTALLY FALSE BUT
FEEL GOOD IF YOU'RE A
LEFT-WINGER.
>> Laura: IT'S FALSE,
DEFAMATORY, AND DEEPLY
VINDICTIVE AT ITS CORE.
I HAVE TO GET YOUR QUICK
THOUGHTS ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THESE HEIGHTENED TENSIONS
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND IRAN.
ASKED IF THE U.S. WAS GOING TO
RETALIATE AFTER ONE OF OUR
DRONES WAS GOING TO SHUT DOWN,
THE PRESIDENT HAD THIS TO SAY.
>> IRAN MADE A BIG MISTAKE I
MADE A MADE A BAD MISTAKE.
[REPORTER QUESTIONING]
>> YOU'LL FIND OUT.
>> Laura: HOW SHOULD WE
RESPOND?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS DOING THE
RIGHT THING, YOU HAVE A HUGE
PROBLEM.
YOU TAKE FULL RESPONSIBILITY IN
WHICH CASE WE HAVE TO RETALIATE
OR YOU HAVE TO FIRE SOMEBODY.
IF YOU WANT TO CLAIM IT WAS A
SUBORDINATE, FINE -- FIRE THEM.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY, REMEMBER THIS.
BECAUSE WE ARE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT, BECAUSE OF THE
POLICIES OF DONALD TRUMP, WE ARE
EXPORTING ENERGY.
WE AREN'T AFFECTED BY THE
STRAIT OF HORMUZ.
CHINA, INDIA, JAPAN, EUROPE,
THEY HAVE A HUGE INVESTMENT IN
THIS.
I SUSPECT WE ARE SAYING TO THEM,
YOU WANT TO HELP US PATROL THE
STREETS OF HER MOOD IS?
YOU'RE THE ONES WHOSE ECONOMY